welcome to google cloud next 2021 in
today's talk secure and reliable
continuous delivery to google kubernetes
engine
in today's talk we're going to talk
through some of the challenges of
continuous delivery to gke
we'll discuss the principles that can be
applied to address those challenges
we'll be introducing google cloud deploy
and finally we'll show a demo
my name is sander bogdan and i'm a
product manager with google cloud and
i'm joined today by brian morgan is an
engineering manager with google cloud
so let's start off by talking about
challenges
over the past 18 months we've had the
opportunity to speak with numerous
google cloud customers about the
continuous delivery challenges they face
with gkg
and from those conversations three
themes emerge
the first theme is cost of ownership
defining robust delivery pipelines
patching tooling and scaling an
organizational continuous delivery
capability can be both difficult and
complex
and even when an organizational
continuous delivery capability has been
established knowing what to measure and
how to optimize those measurements for
success is often unclear
but in all situations continuous
delivery investment intensity can
detract from poor business focus
so the second theme we observed was
around security and audit
controlling releases as they make their
way out to a production environment
approving releases for production
as well as delivery pipeline access
control and audit
were repeated as fundamentally necessary
to modern software delivery
and the final theme was integrations
continuous delivery capability exists
within software delivery ecosystems and
because of that systems integrations
such as with continuous integration
connecting complex workflows such as
multi-step multi-party approvals
and advanced networking requirements
demand continuous delivery tooling
flexibility as well as modularity
and these three themes are best summed
up by a recent customer quote
and that quote went something like this
we cannot afford to be innovating in
continuous delivery
we want an opinionated product that
provides best practices outrobox
and while this quote is associated with
one customer the reality is it could be
assigned to any number of customer
conversations that we've had or now that
we've talked about the challenges i'd
like to talk through some of the
principles that can be applied to
addressing these challenges
so there are four
the first principle is easy
make it easy
to define robust delivery pipelines to
onboard delivery pipelines
scale them
and to apply best practices
as part of their setup
and we believe the best way to do this
is through a managed opinionated service
and brian's going to be talking more
about that later
the second principle is control
it's us delivery tooling must facilitate
manual and automated release control as
it makes its way out to a production
environment
so that includes activities like
promotion rollback as well as approvals
the third principle is security
and what that means is platform
administrators must have the ability to
restrict delivery pipeline definition
and activities
they need to be able to control who is
doing what where and when
and when an audit is needed that should
be handily available too
and the final principle is about
providing insights
so continuous delivery capability must
provide insights both collectively as
well as individually
for delivery pipeline progressions
activities and opportunities to further
optimize delivery stability as well as
release velocity
so again the four principles are make it
easy to make it easy to onboard make it
easy to scale and make it easy to
maintain continuous delivery tooling
using best practices
the second is provide control releases
should be controllable as they make
their way out to a production
environment
the third principle is security control
who can do what where and when with
audit
and finally provide insights to further
optimize your continuous delivery
practices
so now that i've talked through these
principles i'd like to hand it over to
brian who's going to talk to how cloud
google cloud applies these principles
ryan
thanks xander
continuous delivery capabilities
frequently exists within a software
development lifecycle ecosystem this
implies flexibility and modularity as
sander noted
as a delivery tooling requirement
for gcp customers connecting google and
third-party tooling that intersects with
your delivery processes is a necessity
particularly when you already have
continuous integration approval
workflows and associated test automation
we have found that gcp kubernetes
customers typically mature in their
usage of gke over time
starting out customers may have a single
config that targets a single cluster
but this usually grows into multi-config
multi-cluster usage
from there teams often find that
application configuration should be
standardized and source code controlled
allowing them to templatize
configuration changes
finally advanced customers find tools
such as kept and customized to be
extremely useful and allowing them to
make increasingly sophisticated and
automated configuration changes across
environments
most software delivery pipelines can be
thought of as a three-step process
define manage and deliver
because usage of gke is a journey we
advocate using scaffold for the local
development loop
from there scaffold profiles in
combination with a managed continuous
delivery service can be used to define
delivery pipelines and orchestrate
releases
finally that service can actuate the
release to gke target clusters
up until this point we've discussed the
challenges principles and application of
those principles for continuous delivery
into gke
now i'd like to step through the key
features of our recent public preview
launch of google cloud deploy
gcp's continuous delivery service for
google kubernetes engine
we have engineered google cloud deploy
to be a scalable managed service that
enables continuous delivery to gke
cloud deploy relies on a configures code
model with declarative manifests for
configuring the delivery pipelines
in addition it performs gke manifest
rendering and deployment on your behalf
cloud deploy additionally supports a
number of security features including a
discrete iem model
direct integration to gcp cloud audit
logs
manual approvals as part of a deployment
process flow
and even execution on cloud build
private pools for customers that desire
security and control over their
environments
finally cloud deploy has integration
points to enable both google and
third-party delivery related tooling and
process integrations
i'd like to briefly walk you through the
experience before i go into our demo
in this first slide you can see that
google cloud deploy organizes cd
workflows around pipelines which can be
monitored and measured using the gcp
cloud console as well as our g cloud
command line interface and api
next in the delivery pipeline details
view a pipeline's rollouts can be
controlled through promotions and
approvals which are again available via
the cloud console ui and the gcloud cli
you'll also note a delivery pipeline's
release history is accessible for
similar review and taking action
users with appropriate permissions can
then proceed with a release promotion to
evaluate configuration changes that are
included with the release to be deployed
the cloud console user interface
supports direct visual differentials to
aid in the release progression decision
making process
i'd like to now demonstrate the use of
google cloud deploy to deploy an
application to a series of gke target
clusters
in this demo i will step through the
process of creating a gcp cloud deploy
release
deploying to staging then approving a
production rollout
today i'm going to demo the new cloud
deploy service from google we'll start
with a github repo that contains two
applications that will build two
containers
that application is in this example
directory and you'll see there's a
container called leroy app and a second
container called leroy web
both containers include their own
kubernetes deployment manifest
as well as a scaffold config
that defines how those containers will
be built and deployed you can see here
that we're planning to use the standard
cube cuddle deployer to deploy to gk
clusters
if i take a look at gk and my cloud
console you can see that i've already
pre-created three clusters a test
staging and prod so those are already
ready and waiting for me
so the first step i want to do is to go
into cloud shell
i've already pulled the repo down so i
want to do a scaffold build and upload
build and upload those containers to
artifact registry
all right we can see the container build
has finished they have been uploaded i'm
going to go check out my artifact
registry just to verify
yeah we can see now just now
two containers have been uploaded leroy
app and leroy webb
so for my next step i want to actually
now set up my cloud deploy pipeline my
containers are built they're ready
so let's take a look at what that looks
like within my repo you can see i have a
declarative manifest for my pipeline
and it looks just like this and it's
very simple i give it a name which i've
called it web app with a description and
then it really just defines three stages
test staging and prod the order in which
these are defined in or the is basically
the directional flow that the pipeline
will promote through
so let me go into my cloud shell and i'm
going to apply that manifest to cloud
deploy
all right you can see it's now been
applied i can go check out my
cloud deploy user interface
i'm going to do a refresh here
all right now we have a web pipeline
and it's and it's as we mentioned it's
planning to promote from test to staging
to pride
those are actually resources as well
that need to be created and you can see
i have those defined declaratively as
well i have a target test target staging
and target prod
i've defined those in separate manifests
so i'm going to run those in now that
will create each of these targets in
cloud deploy one at a time all of these
could have been added to a single
manifest i just opted not to
all right so i've created
the test target
the staging target
and the production target
at this point
i could do one of two things the first
step i'll take is just to manually
create a release in cloud deploy so i'm
going to go ahead and create
our first released
and we're going to call it web app 001
and you can see now that we've created
the release and it started a roll out to
the first first stage in our pipeline
which we call test
if i take a look at that
you know
you can see the rollout has been queued
it's starting and and this is what the
user interface looks like you know we
show that there's a test a staging and a
prod
[Music]
rollout is skewed if you notice here
between staging and prod it says zero
pending and that what that's referring
to is zero approvals
and it knows that because if we take a
look at our prod manifest
we configured it to require approval so
we'll talk about approvals in a little
bit but effectively
cloud employee is aware and it's
expecting an approval before it goes
allows that promotion to that final
target
while this this pipeline is queued we're
going to go in and i'll show you as well
that i've created a cloud build trigger
that will automatically look for changes
and this is for those that are familiar
with cloud build this is looking at my
git repo and anytime a change happens to
that repo a commit is made it's going to
build a new
uh container upload it to artifact
registry and then you can see here the
second step is it's going to then create
a new release
so we can test that out i will go into
my visual studio code i have a sample
app here
let's just call it
cloud next 21
we're going to update the comment here
apply the change
updated comment
we can see that trigger is running now
and what that trigger is going to do
it's going to update the containers in
the artifact registry and then when
complete it's going to kick off a brand
new release in cloud deploy okay our
trigger has successfully run which
should mean that a cloud deploy release
has been kicked off and we see that it
has
the test has been deployed and now let's
say we want to do a promotion so we're
going to go ahead using the user
interface and force the promotion to
kick off a promotion to the staging
target
okay our promotion to staging was
successful
so now we really have just one step left
that's to promote to production but if
you recall production
also does require a manual approval so
we're going to kick off the promotion
and you can see now we have one pending
review
i'll click the review option that'll go
in there and i can see that oh look i'm
you know i have a i have a rollout that
does need an approval
i do have the appropriate permissions so
i can go in there and review that at
this point i'm ready to approve it i
know what changed i can see i can see
the
the differences
and so
i'm going to approve let me go back to
my pipeline
our promotion to pride was successful
and you can see now we have successfully
promoted
an automated release through test
staging and production this release was
built off of built github trigger
using cloud build
and this this really showcases the
end-to-end ci cd pipeline using both
cloud build and cloud deploy
to learn more about google cloud deploy
visit us at cloud.google.com
deploy
now back to you sander
i'd like to thank you brian for
presenting this talk with me today as
well as all of you for attending google
cloud next 2021